[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم عثمان اي
فرح وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى هذه الصور تاتينا من غزه بعد
ساعات من تصديق الحكومه الاسرائيليه على
اقامه بلده في غلاف القطاع تعد نتيجه اولى
للتحالفات داخل الحكومه الاكثر يمينيه في
تاريخ اسرائيل
ومن كيف تاتينا هذه الصور في وقت يقول فيه
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ان بلاده لن تستخدم
الاسلحه بعيده المدى التي تحصل عليها من
الغرب لاستهداف الاراضي الروسيه
ومن واشنطن هذه الصور في وقت تتواصل فيه
تداعيات قضيه المنطاد الصيني على العلاقات
مع بيجن التي اعتبرت اسقاط منقادها رد فعل
مبالغا فيه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
في اجراء هو الاول من نوعه منذ سنوات
الحكومه الاسرائيليه تصدق على اقامه بلده
جديده في غلاف غزه نتنياهو يؤكد عزمه
تكثيف الانشطه الاستيطانيه ويشدد على ان
الرد على ما وصفه بالارهاب هو تعزيز
الاستيطان
والسلطه الفلسطينيه تندد بحصار الاحتلال
لاريحا وتطالب بضغط امريكي ودولي برفعه
معارك ضاريه في الشرق
الاوكرانيسكي يقر بصعوبه الوضع الميداني
خصوصا في بخموس تعلن تلقيها كل الاسلحه
المطلوبه باستثناء المقاتلات وتؤكد
لحلفائها الغربيين عدم استخدامها في
مهاجمه الاراضي الروسيه وموسكو تتهموكييف
بالتخطيط الافتعال عمليه وهميه
بعد اسقاط المنطاد الصيني فوق الاطلس
بيجين تتهم واشنطن بالمبالغه في رد الفعل
وتحتفظ بحقها في الرد على واشنطن بالوسائل
اللازمه خلال المواقف المماثله والبنتاجون
يواصل جهودا انتشار حطام المنطاد لفحصه
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا اعلان رئيس مجلس السياده
في السودان عبد الفتاح البرهان انه لن
يتراجع عن اتفاق الاطار وان اربع سنوات
مضت منذ ما سماه التغيير لكن دون جديد من
جانبه قال عضو مجلس السياده شمس الدين
الكباشي ان القوات المسلحه لن تمضي في
اتفاق الاطار السياسي ما لم يجمع قدرا
معقولا ومقبولا من القوى السياسيه في حين
قال القيادي وفي حزب البعث وجدي صالح ان
الحديث عن ضروره توسيع مظله التوافق وعدم
تسليم السلطه الا بعد اجماع كامل يعني ان
الانقلاب مستمر
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي في رايكم ما مستقبل
الازمه السياسيه في السودان على ضوء
الخلافات ازاء اتفاق الاطار وقد جاءت
نتيجه تصويتكم على النحو التالي 54% قالوا
ان الازمه تسير نحو مزيد من التعقيد وقال
احد عشر في المئه ان الازمه تتجه نحو
الحلول الجزئيه بينما صوت 35% لاستمرار
الوضع الحالي هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على
منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهره على
الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
مع اشتداد حده العاصفه الثلجيه تزايد
معاناه ملايين النازحين واللاجئين السوري
[موسيقى]
صدق مجلس الوزراء الاسرائيلي على اقامه
بلده جديده في المناطق الاسرائيليه
المتاخمه للحدود مع قطاع غزه وفي الجلسه
الحكوميه قارنت نياهو ان اقامه البلده
دليل اخر على قوه غلاف غزه وقوه اسرائيل
اضافه انه يفخر بتعزيز الاستيطان في جميع
انحاء البلاد حسب قولهم واكد ان الامر
الاكثر اهميه للرد على ما سماه الارهاب هو
تعزيز الاستيطان
على اجنده الحكومه الاكثر يمينيه في تاريخ
اسرائيل الاستيطانو ومزيد من الاستيطان
بالنسبه لبنيامينه نياهو فان ذلك سيكون
الرد الاهم على اعمال المقاومه الفلسطينيه
التي يسميها ارهابا
واولى بوادر ذلك الرد بلده جديده متاخمه
لقطاع غزه صدق على انشائها مجلس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي في اجتماعه الاحد
تقع البلده الجديده المسماه حنون ضمن
كيبوت سعد في غلاف غزه وهي مخصصه لاستيعاب
500 اسره ولا تبتعد سوى سبعه كيلومترات عن
السياج الحدودي شرقي القطاع خطوه بناء
التجمع السكني الجديد تسوقها حكومه
الاحتلال باعتبارها انجازا بالغ الاهميه
فنتنياهو يعتبرها عنوانا لصمود بلدات غلاف
غزه وقوه اسرائيل بينما يراها وزير البناء
والاسكان الاسرائيلي تعزيزا للحدود
الجنوبيه مع قطاع غزه حنون هي اول تجمع
سكاني اسرائيلي يصدق على بنائه منذ سنوات
طويله في غلاف غزه الذي يضم اكثر من خمسين
تجمعا سكنيا وقد عملت حكومات الاحتلال
المتعاقبه على تقديم اغراءات كبيره
تلك البلدات وغالبيتهم من اليهود الشرقيين
ليكونوا بمثابه حاجز جغرافي وديموغرافي
بين القطاع والضفه الغربيه لكن فصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه ترى في التجمعات
السكانيه الاسرائيليه في غلاف غزه الخاصره
الرخوه للاحتلال حيث كانت منذ الانسحاب
الاسرائيلي من غزه عام 2005 في مرمى
صواريخ الفصائل التي طورت ترسانتها لتصبح
ابعد مدى واشد تاثيرا
ينضم الينا من ام الفحم الدكتور مهند
مصطفى مدير مركز مدى الكرمل للدراسات
والخبير في الشان الاستراتيجي دكتور في
بناء هذه البلده
المتاخمه لغلاف غزه الرساله ما هي ولمن
توجه
هنالك رسالتين الرساله الاولى هي
للفلسطينيين
بانهم بان اسرائيل سوف تعود على العمليات
المسلحه والمقاومه الفلسطينيه بمزيد من
البناء الاستيطاني وهذا مقوله يمنيه يعني
دارجه وتقليديه ان الرد على المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وبمزيد من الاستيطان ولكن ايضا
تحمل تحمل رساله الى جمهور اليمين
الاسرائيلي بان هذه الحكومه هي حكومه
يمينيه استيطانيه وتثبت لجمهور اليمين
انها مستمره بالاستيطان وخاصه بعد ان قامت
هذه الحكومه باخلاء بؤره استيطانيه قبل
اسبوعين ولذلك هذه الرساله موجهه
للفلسطينيين وايضا لجمهور اليمين بان هذه
الحكومه لن تتخلى عن خطابها الايديولوجي
وعن هدفها الايديولوجي وهو الاستيطان
والبناء الاستيطاني في كل فلسطين
التاريخيه لانه ذلك جاء في جميع
الاتفاقيات ما بين اللكود وشركائه في
الحكومه بان الاستيطان داخل الخط الاخضر
وخارج الخط الاخضر في الضفه الغربيه هو
هدف استراتيجي لهذه الحكم هل هل يتعمد
نتنياهو هذا الكلام انه تكثيف الاستيطان
في كامل اسرائيل وهو هنا يبني بلده جديده
في اراضي 48
في فلسطين التاريخيه وليس في الاراضي
المحتله سنه 67 فمن ناحيه يعني هو لا يوسع
الاستيطان بين قوسين ولكن عمليا هو يفعل
ذلك هل هذا مقصود
دعني اقول انه الاستيطان في الضفه الغربيه
له مشروع خاص فيه وهو مستمر كل الوقت ليس
في هذه الحكومه حتى في الحكومه السابقه
ولكن الاستيطان في الجنوب بمعنى في منطقه
النقب وفي المناطق المتاخمه لغزه هو اصبح
مشروع يمين جديد في السنوات الاخيره
وبالذات ان هنالك تخوف او صناعه خوف لدى
اليهود بان منطقه الجنوب تم اهمالها وتم
التخلي عنها خصوصا ما يسمى السيطره
البدويه من هذا مصطلح صهيوني السيطره
البدويه على اراضي النقب ولذلك فكره
الاستيطان في الجنوب في النقب وفقه
الاستيطان في الشمال في الجليل هو واحد من
الاهداف الاستراتيجيه لهذه الحكومه اليمين
الاسرائيلي الان لم يعد يفارق ما بين
الاستيطان داخل الخط الاخضر والاستيطان في
الضفه الغربيه هو يربط الامين معا وهذا
رابط هو في محاوله من اليمين لانتاج خطاب
ان الاستيطان واحد والاستيطان هو مشروع
واحد كل يمين في كل فاصلين التاريخيه وان
هنالك ليس هنالك اي خط اخضر ما بين
معينه الاستيطان بالنسبه للامريكيين فيما
يعلنونه على الاقل الاستيطان ليس واحدا
ومن الملفت ان هذا الاجراء جاء بعد جوله
بلينكن التي طالب فيها بوقف المشاريع
والانشطه الاستيطانيه فكيف يرد على
بلنكنياهو كيف يوازن بينما يطلبه والحليف
الامريكي
والضغوط اليمين
المتطرف في حكومته
نعم اولا دعنا نكون بالنسبه لمستوطنه
حانون الجديده لا اعتقد ان الامريكيين سوف
يعارضون عليها لانها بالنسبه لهم تدخل في
نطاق السياده الاسرائيليه يعني داخل خط
الاخضر
ويعتبرونها جزء من القرارات السياديه
لدوره
يعني هل هو اذا هذه الطريقه نعم هل بهذه
الطريقه يلعب على الحبل لين انجاز التعبير
نعم
لا لا يعني سوف يستمر في الاسلام في الضفه
الغربيه ولكن ليس بالكثافه ربما في هذه
المرحله اقل بكثافه التي يريدها مثلا
احزاب اليمين في الحكومه مثل
وسوف يستمر في الاستيطان في الضفه الغربيه
وسوف يعزز الاستيطان ولكن بايقاع الذي لا
يثير غضب الامريكيين فيما يتعلق
بالاستيطان داخل خط الاخضر وبالذات في
النقب وفي الجليل الامريكيون لن يتدخلون
في ذلك انه يعتبرون ذلك سياده اسرائيليه
اسرائيل سوف تستغل ذلك يعني البناء في
الجنوب والشمال وليس بناء موجه يعني على
مستوى الدول او اسرائيل لا تاخذ في اي
اعتراض هذا جزء من اسياد الاسرائيليه هو
موجه بالاساس نحو الفلسطينيين في داخل
الخط الاخضر ضد الفلسطينيه من اجل التضييق
على حيزهم ولكن ايضا هو موجه لجمهور
اليمين الاسرائيلي الذي يريد مزيدا من
الاستيطان في الجليد والنقب ولا يريد ان
يتم التفرقه ما بين الاستيطان في داخل
الخط الاخضر وال في الضفه الغربيه من نسبه
له وكان هنالك في تهميش والتخلي عن النقب
والجليل والحكومه جاءت تقول وهذا واحد من
برامجها الاساسيه واحد من برامج الحكومه
هذه صحيح هو
المكثف في الجليل والنقب ايضا من اجل
التضييق التضييق على الفلسطينيين وعلى
حيزهم في داخل الخط الاخضر شكرا جزيلا من
ام الفحم الدكتور مهند مصطفى مدير مركز
مدى الكرمل للدراسات والخبير في الشان
الاسرائيلي
دانت وزاره الخارجيه الفلسطينيه الحصار
الذي تفرضه سلطاته الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
على مدينه اريحا لليوم الثامنه على
التوالي يتعرض له المواطنين كذلك من
احتجاز وانتظار لساعات طويله اثناء تنقلهم
او سفرهم او عودتهم وقالت انه انتهاك صارخ
للقانون الدولي والانساني والاتفاقيات
الموقعه وطالبت بضغط دولي وامريكي على
الحكومه الاسرائيليه لرفع هذا الحصار عن
مدينه اريحا
يذكر ان قوات الاحتلال نفذت امس عمليه
عسكريه في مخيم عقبه جبر في اريحا استغرقت
اكثر من ثلاث ساعات وفشلت في اعتقال منفذي
عمليه اطلاق النار على مطعم للمستوطنين
قرب اريحا وما زالت تشدد اجراءاتها على
الحواجز العسكريه عند مخارج المدينه
[موسيقى]
في اوكرانيا يشتد القتال في اقليم دومباس
الشرقيه البلاد فالمعارك في مدينه باخموت
هي الاكثر احتداما في هذه الايام وقد
تحدثت ميليشيا فاجنر عن قتال مع القوات
الاوكرانيه في شوارع الاحياء الشماليه من
المدينه مشيره الى استماته القوات
الاوكرانيه الموجوده هناك من جانبها اعلنت
القوات المواليه لروسيا في دنيسك سيطرتها
على بعض مداخل مدينه اوغوليدار وانها
ستبدا تطويق قريبا وفق تعبيرها
في الجهه المقابله ذكرت قياده الاركان
الاوكرانيه ان القوات الروسيه تعيد تجميع
صفوفها على محاور القتال في الاقليم عند
مدن بخموت ولمان وافديفكا
واكدت صدها محاولات عده للقوات الروسيه
للتقدم على تسعه محاور في الاقليم
في خضم هذه التطورات قرر رئيس الاوكراني
فولودي بصعوبه المعركه على الخطوط
الاماميه قائلا ان الوضع يزداد تعقيدا
زيلينسكي اتهم روسيا بحشد المزيد من
القوات لكسر الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه
وكان الرئيس الاوكراني اعلن بدء تدريبات
قواته على دبابات تشالنجر في بريطانيا
وقال ان ذلك سيكون له دور حاسم في ساحه
المعركه
من جهه اخرى اعلن وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه
او الاكسي تعهد بلاده بعدم استخدام
الاسلحه الغربيه لضرب الاراضي الروسيه
مشيرا الى تعويل بلاده على هذه الاسلحه
لكسب المعركه على الارض وكان المستشار
الالماني قال ان هناك اجماعا بين الدول
الغربيه على ان استخدام الاسلحه الغربيه
الجديده المقدمه
سيقتصر على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
لا يكفي مدى هذه الاسلحه لضرب الخطوط
الخلفيه البعيده للقوات الروسيه ولذلك ظلت
اوكرانيا تليح على الدول الغربيه لمدها
باسلحه ذات مدى بعيد
هذه دبابات اثنان التي وافقت المانيا على
مد اوكرانيا بها بعد موافقه واشنطن على
تقديم دبابات ابرامز حتى الان وافقت بلين
على تسليم اربعه عشره منها لكنها تشترط
الا تستهدف الاسلحه الجديده الاراضي
الروسيه
في حوار مع مجله بيلد قال المستشار
الالماني او لافشولت ان هناك اجماعا بين
الدول الغربيه على ان استخدام الاسلحه
التي ستقدمها سيقتصر على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه لتفادي تصعيد الحرب يدرك
الاوكرانيون ان ما يقوله شورت شرط لتقديم
الاسلحه الجديده ولذلك سعى وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني لطمانه الجميع
اخبرنا شركائنا اننا ملتزمون بعدم استخدام
الاسلحه التي نتلقاها الاستهداف الاراضي
الروسيه وان استخدامها سيقتصر على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه المحتله مؤقتا بهدف تحريرها
تعهدت الولايات المتحده بمساعدات عسكريه
جديده لاوكرانيا بقيمه مليارين ومئتين
مليون دولار الجديد في هذه المساعدات انها
تضم اسلحه متطوره بعيده المدى ومنها
قاذفات جي ال اس دي بي التي يبلغ مداها
150 كيلومترا اي ما يقارب ضعف مدى قاذفات
هاي مارس التي قدمت هذه في يونيو الماضي
يقول الاوكرانيون ان الروس تعلموا من
اخطائهم وصاروا يضعون ذا خائرهم على بعد
80 الى 120 كيلومترا من خط الجبهه لتفادي
ضربات هاي مارس
[تصفيق]
مع الاسلحه الجديده ستصبح كل القوات
الروسيه داخل المناطق التي ضمتها في
اوكرانيا بما في ذلك شمال شبه جزيره القرم
في مرمى القوات الاوكرانيه من وجهه نظر
روسيا كل الاقاليم الاوكرانيه التي ضمتها
اصبحت اراضيه روسيه ولذلك فهي تنظر الى
تسليمها للاسلحه لاوكرانيا كاعتداء عليها
المتحدث باسم الكرملين
كييف اسلحه يصل مداها الى 150 كيلومترا
سيؤدي الى تصعيد الحرب كل المؤشرات تقول
ان التصعيد قادم وان الغرب بتقديمه اسلحه
لاوكرانيا كان يتردد في تقديمها دخل في
حرب استنزاف مع روسيا
ينضم الينا من كييف اوليكس مساعد وزير
الدفاع الاوكرانيه السابق ومن موسكو
اندريه والخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه
اهلا بكم ولكن قبل ذلك انوه الى بعض
الاخبار العاجله
ومنها انا وسائل الاعلام الاوكرانيه تنقل
عن وزير الداخليه نقل وزير الدفاع الحالي
الى منصب وزير الدفاعات وتعيين
وهناك تعيين اللواء كاريلو اودانوف وزيرا
جديدا
للدفاع وعن ذلك سوف اسال السيد ميلك هو
بمساعد وزير الدفاع الاوكراني السابق هل
من تعليق على هذا القرار
فيما يخص وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
كان هناك فضيحه مرتبطه بالفساد على مستوى
وزاره الدفاع الوزير بنفسه لم يتهم ولكن
بصفته وزيرا وبصفته شخصيه سياسيه اتخذ هذا
القرار او الرئيس فولوديم
قرر ان يستبدله بوزير اخر اذا كان محترفا
ومهنيا للغايه ولكن كما سبق واسلفت لربما
هذا التعيين الجديد يرتبط بفضيحه الفساد
هل له علاقه بصعوبات يتحدث عنها الرئيس
زيلينسكي خاصه في بخموت ما يعني طبيعه
الصعوبات او التعقيدات التي يتحدث عنها
الرئيس الاوكراني في تلك الجبهة
الدفاع
المدني ليس القائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحه
وليس مسؤولا عن اجراء العمليات
نحن نتحدث عن وزير مدني مسؤوليته ان يقدم
للقوات المسلحه
الامور الضروريه لاداء المهام المطلوبه
منها بالنسبه الى بخموت نعم بالفعل الوضع
هناك في غايه الصعوبه
والقوات الروسيه تحاول ان تحاصر مخموت
للدخول اليها منذ سته اشهر تقريبا من دون
تحقيق نجاحات مهمه ولكن اذا ما استمرت
القوات الروسيه
بجهودها قد تتمكن من القيام بذلك في غضون
اسب عواشر
الاوكرانيون اكدوا انهم لن يستخدموا
الاسلحه التي حصل عليها خاصه الصواريخ
بعيده المدى في استهداف ارادي روسيه ولكن
فقط في تحرير الاراضي الاوكرانيه المحتله
هل هذا مطمئن للروس كيف ينظرون اليه
على المستوى الشخصي انا لا اصدق هذه
المزاعم وهذه التصريحات لانه ما من
مصداقيه
لها واذا ما كانت صحيحه
يمكننا ان نتحدث لسوء الحظ عن اهداف في
شبه جزيره القرم وكما يعرف الجميع ان شبه
الجزيره
هي اراد روسيه وبالتالي
باستطاعاتهم ان يدمروا الاهداف المدنيه
والعسكريه في شبه جزيره القرم بالنسبه الى
روسيا اذا هذه الاسلحه تشكل تهديدات لذلك
قال وزير الخارجيه
ان روسيا سوف تضغط على الحدود مع اوكرانيا
في ظروف مماثله للدفاع عن اراضيها سيد هل
يمكن القول ان هذه كانت شروط غربيه لتسليم
هذه الاسلحه للاوكرانيين
هناك اتفاق شرف بان
الاوكرانيين لن يستخدموا الاسلحه الغربيه
لقصف الاهداف على الاراضي الروسيه ولكن
شبه جزيره القرم هي
ليست ارادا روسيه بالنسبه الى الاسره
الدوليه نحن نتحدث عن اراد محتله بشكل غير
قانوني وبالتالي شبه جزيره القرم هي قضيه
مختلفه بالمناسبه هناك ضربات تمت واستهدفت
شبه جزيره القرم من خلال المسيرات ومن
خلال القصف المدفعي الذي استهدف في شبه
جزيره القرم الذي سادف شبه جزيره القرم لم
يكن هناك رد فعل من جانب روسيا ولكننا
نتحدث عن
منفصله ووضع منفصل لكن نعم هناك اتفاق
بالاتستخدم القوات الاوكرانيه هذه الاسلحه
لقصف الاراضي الروسيه سيد الى اي مدى يمكن
ان يصعب هذا الامر في المعارك
المتوقعه او في العمليات التي تنوي روسيا
شنها في ذكرى مرور سنه على بدايه هذه
الحرب
لا اعتقد ان الاسلحه الجديد من شانها ان
تغير الزخم وان تغير المعادله في الميدان
والتوازن الميداني لان الجميع يرى القدرات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه
والقدرات العسكريه الروسيه هناك اختلاف
شاسع بينهما اوكرانيا لا يمكنها ان تواجه
روسيا من دون الدعم الغربي وهناك اختلافات
في وجهه النظر بالنسبه الى الدعم الغربي
لاوكرانيا من حيث الاسلحه والذخيره التي
بدات تنفذ لذلك اعتقد ان روسيا باستطاعتها
ان تشن
حمله واسعه النطاق باتجاه اوكرانيا كما
يتوقع المحللون واعتقد انها سوف تكون في
الاسابيع المقبله هل تعتقد ان ان تؤثر
كثيرا في هذه المعارك المتوقعه قريبا وتلك
التي يتم الحديث عنها في الربيع المقبل
ايضا
يمين كنا نتحدث عن تاثير الاسلحه
التي وعدت بها الدول الغربيه بكل تاكيد
وخصوصا الدبابات نحن لا نعرف عدد الدبابات
لربما نتحدث عن 100 دبابه ولكن في افضل
السيناريوهات تقدم
لاوكرانيا وتستخدم في الميدان تكون جاهزه
للاستخدام بحلول فصل الصيف وبالتالي
العمليه الروسيه اذا ما بدات في الاسابيع
المقبله والاشهر المقبله يتعين على
اوكرانيا ان تستخدم الاسلحه المتاحه لها
الان ولكن بالنسبه الى اهميه الدبابات
الغربيه الجديده هي ان هذه الدبابات تعطي
حركه اكبر للقوات الاوكرانيه ولكي تتمكن
القوات الاوكرانيه من استخدام الموارد
المتاحه بشكل افضل القوات الاوكرانيه
لديها حوالي 1000 دبابه قتاليه سوفياتيه
ما الذي يمكن توقعه عسكريا خلال الاسابيع
المقبله في روسيا في ذكرى مرور سنه على
اندلاع هذا هذه الحرب ونحن نتحدث عن بدايه
توجه القوات الروسيه نحو كييف قبل نحو عام
ان النقطه الاهم في الاسابيع المقبله هي
سقوط ضخمه
لصالح القوات الروسيه باضافه الى اوغلادار
على الارجح لاننا نرى ان الجيش الاوكراني
ليس باستطاعته ان يدافع عنها بمواجهه
العمليه الروسيه اما بالنسبه الى شهر مارس
ادار وشهر ابريل نيسان يصعد ان نتوقع
الاحداث لذلك
لا يمكنني ان اتوقع ما الذي سوف يحصل بعد
جبهه
شكرا جزيلا لكم من موسكو اندريه والخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي وملكيه
مساعد وزير الدفاع الاوكراني السابق
وسبقنا سبق فنبقى في كييف تنضم الينا من
هناك مراسله الجزيره كاترين حن وذلك لمزيد
من التفاصيل كاترين عن هذا القرار بتعيين
وزير دفاع جديد
نعم عثمان منذ قليل اعلن رئيس الكتله
البرلمانيه لحزب لحزب خادم الشعب وهو
الكتله البرلمانيه الاكبر وحزب الرئيس
فولدمير زيلنسكي اعلن انه سوف
ينقل وزير الدفاع الحالي اوليكس الى منصب
وزير الصناعات الاستراتيجيه وسوف يتم
تعيين اخر مكانه وهو رئيس المديريه
الرئيسيه للمخابرات في وزاره الدفاع
كيريلو بودانوف واوضح رئيسه هذه الكتله
البرلمانيه واذكر بانها كتله خادم الشعب
الكتله الاكبر في البرلمان ان الحرب
والوضع الحالي يتطلب اعاده تجميع واعاده
نظر في كل شيء وان الوزير ريزني كوف هو
باق داخل الحكومه ولكن سيتم نقله الى
وزاره الصناعات الاستراتيجيه
لتعزيز التعاون في موضوع الصناعه العسكريه
لاسيما وانه كان له دور كبير في اجتماع
رمشتاين الاخير حتى هذه اللحظه لم تحصل
الاستقاله ولا تعيين احد طبعا يتوقع ان
تعقد جلسه للبرلمان الاوكراني عثمان
الاسبوع المقبل ويتم خلال هذه الجلسه
اقاله الوزير ريزني كوف وتعيين الوزير
الجديد في منصب بوزاره الدفاع علما ان هذه
القرارات كانت متوقعه بحيث انه قبل ساعات
قليله كان الوزير نفسه قد تحدث عن احتمال
استقالته في حال طلب منه الرئيس ديلينسكي
ذلك يبدو ان الرئيس قد طلب ذلك فعلا علما
ان مستشار الرئيسكي ومنذ لحظات قليله كان
قد تحدث عن ان روزني كوف وزير الدفاع
المقال الذي سوف يتم تعيين احد مكانه في
وقت قريب هو نفسه كان نشيطا جدا بحسب مقال
مستشار المستشار في الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
ميخائيل بودولياك وقد لعب دورا اساسيا في
الحوار مع شركاء اوكرانيا في مساله
التسليح علما ان موضوع التسليح وحاجه
اوكرانيا للصواريخ البعيده المدى ولمزيد
من الاسلحه الثقيله طبعا هو موضوع اساسي
لذلك اكتسب هذا الخبر اهميه كبيره في
اوكرانيا وهو ياتي ضمن حمله لمكافحه
الفساد كانت قد بدات قبل اسابيع عثمان
شكرا جزيلا لك منك مراسله الجزيره كاترين
حنا
دخل حظر النفط الروسي ومشتقاته ووضعه سقف
سعري للبرميل حيز التنفيذ والذي سبقه حظر
بحري على هذه الصادرات ادى الى انخفاض
عائدات موسكو خلال شهر كانون الثاني يناير
قرابه 30 في المئه من عائداتها مقارنه مع
الفتره نفسها من العام الماضي الا ان
خبراء يقولون بامكانيه التفاف روسيا على
هذه العقوبات عبر دول لم تلتزم بالحظر
المفروض
التاريخ المنشود قد حل حظر الاتحاد
الاوروبي ودول السبعه على الصادرات روسيا
من النفط ومشتقاته دخل حيز التنفيذ ومعه
تحديد سقف لاسعار النفط الروسي بنحو 60
دولارا للبرميل فما الذي يعنيه برميل
النفط الروسي لا يتم تداوله باعلى من 60
دولارا للبرميل في وقت يصل فيه السعر
المرجعي اي متوسط سعر البرميل حاليا لنحو
79 دولارا فهل تطبيق العقوبات ممكن
وبسهوله الاجابه المقتضبه ممكن ولكن يتعين
بدايه اقناع اكبر مستهلكين نفط الخام
الروسي الصين والهند بالموافقه على الحظر
والسقف السعري
الصين هي اكبر مستورد للنفط الخام الروسي
باكثر من مليون برميل يوميا والهند
تقاربها من حيث معدل الاستيراد والدولتان
اصلا تنالان معامله تفضيليه من روسيا
روسيا مسؤوله عن انتاج قرابه عشره ونصف في
المئه من النفط الخام عالميا وهي كميه قد
تكون مؤثره في تحقيق اهداف العقوبات
فالطلب العالمي مرشح للارتفاع خاصه مع
انتعاش الاقتصاد الصيني والاستثمارات
العالميه في مشاريع الطاقه الاحفوريه سجل
التراجعا ملموسا فماذا لو قررت روسيا وقف
صادرتها تلقائيا او الالتفاف على العقوبات
سيدخل الاقتصاد العالمي في ازمه ارتفاع
اسعار النفط وبالتالي ينعكس ذلك على اسعار
السلع والخدمات وستبقى الدول المستفيده
تلك التي تتعامل مع روسيا الصين والهند
وغيرهما يمكن للهند مثلا او دوله اخرى
للالتفاف على العقوبات بفتح باب خلفي
للنفط الروسي تستورده تكرره وتعيد بيعه مع
الاخذ في الاعتبار ان موسكو تؤكد انها
ستتخذ التدابير الحمائيه اللازمه لكن
العقوبات اثرت بالطبع لعائدات موسكو من
النفط والغاز سجل الشهر الماضي انخفاضا
بنحو 30% مقارنه بالفتره نفسها العام
الماضي وخسرت روسيا قرابه ثمانيه مليارات
دولار الا ان تقارير اقتصاديه تقول انه من
المرجح تلاشي اثار العقوبات بمرور الوقت
فمن سيصرخ اولا روسيا ام اقتصاد السوق
وكانت وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه جانتيه لان
اول المرحبين بالقرار الاوروبي القاضي
بتحديد سقف لاسعار المشتقات البترونيه
الروسيه وقالت الوزيره الامريكيه ان
الحدود القصوى الجديده لاسعار منتجات
النفط الروسيه ستحد بشكل اكبر من عائدات
روسيا مع الحفاظ على امدادات اسواق الطاقه
العالميه
في المقابل ندد الكرملين بقرار الاتحاد
الاوروبي بتحديد سقف الاسعار وقال المتحدث
باسم الكرملين
ان الحضره الاوروبيه سيعمق من انعدام
التوازن في اسواق الطاقه العالميه
واضاف بسكوب ان الروسيا ستتخذ اجراءات
لحمايه مصالحها من مخاطر وتداعيات القرار
الاوروبي
اثار اسقاط المنطاد الصيني بصاروخ امريكي
في ولايه كارولاينا الجنوبيه استياء من
بيجين التي اتهمت واشنطن بالمبالغه وكان
وزير الدفاع الامريكي اعلن في بيان تفاصيل
عمليه الاسقاط مؤكدا استخدام الصين
للمنطاد من اجل التجسس على مواقع حساسه
وكانت اولى تداعيات هذه الازمه تاجيله
زياره وزير الخارجيه انتن بلينكن والتي
كانت مقرره يوم الاثنين مما يبعد فرصه
هدنه في الحرب الدبلوماسيه والتجاريه
المستعره بين البلدين
اسقط المنطادو على التوتر بين الصين
والولايات المتحده بصاروخ واحد ومن طائره
اف 22 تحول عنوان اخر ازمه بين البلدين
الى حطام سينتشر من المياه الضحله التي
وقع فيها كيف ومن سيلملم شظايا تداعيات
التصعيد تبع بعض الامريكيين العرض العسكري
السياسي التجسس عن قرب قباله سواحل ولايه
كارولاين الجنوبيه اتضح ان قرار الاسقاط
تاجل لاسباب امنيه ولم يستبعد كما قيل في
الايام الاولى لتفجر الازمه وجاء في بيان
وزير الدفاع الامريكي
ان عمليه اسقاط المنطاد هي رد على انتهاك
غير مقبول لسياده بلاده مؤكدا ان الصين
استخدمته في محاوله لمراقبه المواقع
الحساسه
توجه الرئيس جو بايدن بالتهنئه للطيارين
الذين نفذوا العمليه وبدات تصريحاته
بالقول انه اصدر امرا للبينتاغون منذ عده
ايام باسقاط المنقاد الصيني فوق المياه
بدلا من المخاطره بسقوط الحطام في مناطق
ماهوله بالسكان اثار رد الفعل الامريكي
غضب بيجين التي اتهمت واشنطن بالمبالغه
ورد في بيان الخارجيه استياء الصين الشديد
واحتجاجها على استخدام القوه من الولايات
المتحده لمهاجمه المنطاد المدني غير
الماهون الروايه الرسميه لبيجين منذ بدات
القضيه هي ان المنطاد يستخدم في مجال
الارصاد الجويه ودخل عن غير قصد وبقوه
قاهره الاجواء الامريكيه كلام لم يقنع
البيت الابيض ولا البنتاجون بينما اقتنع
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلينكين ان
الظروف الحاليه غير ملائمه للقيام بزيارته
التي مقرره للصين يوم الاثنين قرروا
الارجاء اتخذ الجمعه الماضيه ردا على
اختراق المنطاد اجواء امريكا الشماليه
وبذلك يؤجل اي تقارب حتى ولو كان ضئيلا في
علاقات واشنطن التي تمر بالسنوات التصعيد
عابر للقارات والمحيطات قضايا خلافيه
كثيره تجعل الحرب الدبلوماسيه والتجاريه
بينهما مستعره من تايوان الى المحيط
الهادي وبحر جنوب الصين الى التقارب
المقلق لواشنطن وحلفائها بين
الرئيسينغ وبوتين لا شيء قد يساعد الان
على هدنه ما
وعشنتا تتهم بيجين بتزويد موسكو بالاسلحه
في حرب اوكرانيا وبمساعدتها على الالتفاف
على العقوبات الدوليه من حيث التوقيت دخل
المنطاد الصيني اجواء علاقات مشحونه جدا
واسقاطه في مياه المحيط يغرق قوتين في
صراع
وخطير حتى بدون مواجهه عسكريه تقليديه
مباشره على الاقل حتى اللحظه
من اين اقلع المنطاد وكيف وصل الى
الولايات المتحده ولماذا تاخرت واشنطن في
اسقاطه اسئله كثيره نجيب عليها في العرض
التالي
يوم الجمعه الاخيره من شهر يناير بدات
رحله منطاد الازمه بين الصين والولايات
المتحده
وفق التقديرات فان المنطاد عبر المحيط
الهادئ دخل الاجواء الامريكيه فوق ولايه
الاسكا بعد 24 ساعه امضى السبت والاحد في
اجواء الاسكا ثم دخل المجال الجوي الكندي
يوم الاثنين دخل المنطاد المجال الجوي
الامريكي مره اخرى في اجواء ولايه عايده
يوم الثلاثاء بدات فكره اسقاطه لكن
المسؤولين الامريكيين لم يتمكنوا من تحديد
المخاطر على الناس اليوم الاول من الشهر
الحالي دخل المنطاد اجواء مونتانا وحلق
بالقرب من قاعده الجويه تضم القاعده
العديد من قواعد الصواريخ النوويه رسد من
المدنيين واغلق المطار الدولي مؤقتا هنا
اذن الرئيس الامريكي باسقاط المنقاد دون
مخاطر على الناس بعد يوم كشف المسؤولون
الامريكيون ان المنطاد كان يح فوق البر
الرئيسي للولايات المتحده لعده ايام بعد
اسبوع على انطلاق المنطاد من الصين رصده
مدنيون اثناء تحليقه فوق
هنا اعترفت الصين بالمنطاد لكنها قالت انه
مخصص للطقس وانحرف عن مساره معتذره
للولايات المتحده عن دخوله الاجواء
الامريكيه بالخطا في اليوم التالي اتخذ
القرار بتنفيذ عمليه الاسقاط غادر المنطاد
البر الامريكي اثناء تحليقه فوق المحيط
الاطلسي قباله ساحلي ولايه كارولاينا
الجنوبيه تكفلت طائره اف 22
بمواجهه المنطاد على ارتفاع يتراوح بين 18
و19 كيلومترا اطلقت الاف 22 صاروخا انفجر
قرب المنطاد وحرقه وسقط اعلن وزير الدفاع
الامريكي انه لم تسجل اي اضرار جانبيه او
خسائر في عمليه الاسقاط الامنه بالتنسيق
مع الحكومه الكنديه رد المبالغ فيه وينتهك
الممارسات الدوليه تعليق الخارجيه على
العمليه هكذا يبدو ان ازمه المنطاد في
شكلها التقني والعسكري قد انتهت لكنها على
الاغلب لم تنتهي في شكلها السياسي بين
بلدين يسود التوتر العلاقه بينهما
[موسيقى]
الدكتور زينو اليوني الاستاذ بقسم
الدراسات الدفاعيه في جامعه كينج والخبير
في الشؤون الصينيه الدكتور انتظرت الاجهزه
الامنيه والاستخباراتيه الامريكيه ثلاثه
ايام قبل ان تخطر الرئيس بايدن بشان هذا
البالون ما يعني انها كل هذه الفتره لم
تعتبر ان انه خطر يستدعي ابلاغ الرئيس فما
الذي تغير بعد ثلاثه ايام
اعتقد ان عدم اليقين هذا يعكس عدم اليقين
الحاضر
بالسياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه تجاه الصين
بشكل عام ولكن اعتقد في نهايه المطاف ان
الاداره ورئيس بايدن على وجه الخصوص اتخذ
القرار باسقاط المنطاد اولا لان الموضوع
بحاجه الى ادله وايضا برزت اصوات من
الصقور في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تضغط على البيت الابيض لمعرفه المزيد حول
هذا المنطاد وبالتالي اراد الرئيس بايدن
ان يظهر لي الناخبين الامريكيين ولشعب
الامريكي انه هو من بادر بالامر باسقاط
المنطاد يصعب ان نقول متى تغير وماذا تغير
الامر
تغيير الامر وما الذي تغير ولكن الرئيس
بايدن اتخذ القرار بعد ضغط من الناخبين في
الولايات المتحده وزير الخارجيه كان يفترض
ان يذهب الاثنين الى بيجين هذه الزياره
الغيت وبالتالي هذه حادثه وانتهت ام نحن
بصدد ازمه عميقه مع حجم التوتر بين
البلدين
اعتقد ان زياره وزير الخارجيه بلنكن سوف
يعاد جدولتها طبعا هذا طبيعي ان تعلق نظرا
للاحداث اذا بشكل عام اي ازمه يمكن النظر
لها على الامد القريب والبعيد بالنسبه الى
الامد القصير في هذه الازمه بالتحديد طبعا
هناك مشكله بين الولايات المتحده والصين
هناك مشاكل حول التغير المناخي وكوفيد
والان المنطاد ولكن اذا ما عدنا الى
المنظور التاريخي الذي يمتد على 50 عام
على سبيل المثال نرى مطبات في العلاقه بين
البلدين ولكن كلا الطرفين تمكن من تخطي اي
تصعيد وهذا ما سوف يحصل في القريب العاشر
من لندن الدكتور زينه الاستاذ في قسم
الدراسات الدفاعيه في جامعه كينج كوليج
والخبير في الشؤون الصينيه شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
في سوريا افاد مراسل الجزيره بان الاف
العائلات في مخيمات النازحين في ريفي حلب
وادلب شمال الغربي البلاد يعيشون اوضاعا
صعبه بسبب تاثر مخيماتهم بتساقط الثلوج
والامطار مع بدء المنخفضه الجويه في
المنطقه
تزداد الاوضاع الانسانيه سوءا في مخيمات
النازحين بريف ادلب الغربي مع اشتداد
المنخفض الجوي وتشكل الضباب وانخفاض درجات
الحراره الاف العائلات تشكو ضعف استجابه
المنظمات الانسانيه ووكالات الغوص في
مخيمات تفتقر الى ادنى مقومات العيش
الكريم منذ قليل التقينا باحد اطفال
عائلتي ام محمد وحدثنا بغصه وحرقه عما
تعانيه العائله من مصاعب في هذا المنخفض
الجوي ندخل الخيمه
لنلتقي بمحمد وتحدثنا اكثر عن تفاصيل هذه
المعاناه السلام عليكم اختي محمد تحكيلنا
عن وضع العيله بشكل عام
الحمد لله عندي خمس اولاد وجوزي مريض قلب
ولادي كمان مرضانين
تعرف نظر ورب وبرد يعني شوفت عينك ما في
لا حطب لا في اي شيء نتدفى عليه وما حدا
اجا لا منظمات ولا اي شيء عين بحالنا ابدا
يعني
شافت عينك مرض وبرد يعني وضعنا كتير سيء
اذا عقله ام محمد هي عينه من الاف
العائلات التي تعاني وتتفاقم معاناتها مع
بدايه المنخفض الجوي
هذه العائلات بدات توجه رسائل الى المجتمع
الدولي
بضروره ايجاد حل جذري للتخلص من هذه
المعاناه وهي عودتهم الى ديارهم وبيوتهم
وارزاقهم وانتهاء هذا التعب
ادمه ابو حسام الجزيره
بدوره يشهد لبنان رياحا قطبيه وتساقطا
للثلوج على المناطق الجبليه وهو ما فاقم
معاناه اللاجئين السوريين في تلك المناطق
صغار كبير على المعاناه في مخيمات عرسال
شرقيه لبنان اما الكبار بينهم فيواجهون
مشقه العيش في هذه الظروف المناخيه
القاسيه
دمرت خيمه موسى قبل ايام فاضطر للانتقال
مع عائلته الى خيمه ثلاثه عشر شخصا يعيشون
هنا اما وسيله تدفئه الوحيده فهي القماش
والبلاستيك حتى لعبه العيش صعبه
النوب انت بتنامي وتفكري شلون بدي اتدفوا
الاولاد ولا ياكلوا ولا شو ولا دواء ولا
اذا واحد مريضه دواء ولا اكل ولا تدفئه كل
اليوم صعب وقد فاقم معاناه اللاجئين
السوريين في لبنان قرار الهيئات التابعه
للامم المتحده شطب الاف اللاجئين من برامج
المساعدات لديها
البرنامج الامم المتحده السابقه ما بيعرف
وهاي يعني مخونه
يعني ناس بيعطونا بيعطوه ليش من جهتها
تحاول المنظمات المحليه على قله مواردها
تامين ما تيسر لسد الحد الادنى من حاجات
اللاجئين اذا استمر تخليص التمويل على
الشكل الذي نحن عليه اليوم فنحن مضطرين
لتخليص حجم المساعدات للاجئه السوري مما
سيضطره لمواجهه الاسماء الاقتصاديه
وحيدا حرم داء السكري ام محمد من قدرتها
على النظر والسير وز عليها عدم قدرتها على
تامين ثمن العلاج نعسنا يعني الابر منشان
يتقوى يعني العظم اللي كانوا يعطوني اياهن
والله تحسنت عليهم بس صاروا غاليين
الاف ولاجئين تركوا لمصيرهم ليس في هذه
العاصفه فحسب بل في مواجهه كل الازمات
التي تعصف بلبنان
عشره سنه وما زالت معاناه اللاجئين
السوريين في لبنان مستمره وما البرد
القارص الا واحد من فصولها الموجعه فهؤلاء
باتوا محاصرين بين واقع معيشي مرير وغياب
اي حلول تضع حدا لماساتهم كارمنج خضار
الجزيره عرسال شرقيه لبنان
اجواء صعبه وتتواصل ماساه ملايين من
النازحين واللاجئين السوريين الذين يعانون
ظروفا قاسيه جراء منخفض جوي شديد وتراجع
للمعونات الدوليه نتحدث تحديدا عن الشمال
السوري الذي تنتشر فيه مخيمات للنازحين في
مناطق من بينها عفرين واعزاز واطمع ويعيش
اكثر من مليون ونصف مليون سوري في مخيمات
على الشريط الحدوديه التركيه السوري في
ريفي ادلب وحلب وتفتقد هذه المخيمات
للبنيه التحتيه الاساسيه من طرقات ومياه
وصرف صحي شبكات صرف الصحي وهو ما يضع
ساخنيها عرضه لتكرار المساله كل شتاء
ننتقل الى مخيمات بلده عرسال في الشرق
اللبناني حيث يعيش قرابه 80 الف لاجئ سوري
وسط ظروف تزداد صعوبه اضافه الى ذلك يعيش
قرابه اربعين الف لاجئ سوري في
تقع في جنود البلده وسط غياب لادنى
متطلبات العيش وقد افاد الدفاع المدني
السوري بتضرر مخيمات عده في شمال غربي
سوريا وذلك بسبب العاصفه المستمره شمال
البلاد التي ادت ادت العاصفه الى انقطاع
عدد كبير من الطرقات في اكثر من 30 قريه
وبلده بريف حلب لغه الارقام توضح اكثر عدد
المخيمات الكلي شمال غربي سوريا على
الحدود السوريه التركيه يفوق 1630
مخيما عدد النازحين الكلي في المخيمات
يزيد على مليون
وثمانمائه الف ونسبه العجز في الاستجابه
الانسانيه في المخيمات باقطاع الصحه
والتغذيه تناهز اربعه وثمانين في المئه
ثمانيه
وخمسون في المئه من النازحين لم يحصلوا
على مواد التدفئه هذا العام وخارج الحدود
تحديدا في لبنان يعيش في المئه من
اللاجئين السوريين الواقعين تحتف خط الفقر
المتقع حسب مفوضيه شؤون اللاجئين التابعه
للامم المتحده وللحديث اكثر عن ذلك تنضم
الينا من عمان رولا امينه المتحدثه باسم
المفوضيه الامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين
رولا اهلا وسهلا بك هذه الماساه تتكرر كل
شتاء فما هو السبيل لعدم تكرارها او الحد
منها على الاقل
طبعا هو وضع ماساوي اننا كل شتاء نتحدث في
نفس الموضوع والمعاناه مستمره كما تفضلت
كارمن 12 عام مرت على الازمه السوريه وكل
يوم يصبح الوضع اصعب بالنسبه للنازحين
داخل سوريا واللاجئين خارجها للاسف
العاصفه تبدا الان نحن نتوقع اوضاع وعواصف
وبرد
وثلوج اكثر خلال اليومين المقبلين وهذا
يعني ان التحديات امام هؤلاء العائله امام
هذه العائلات لتبقى دافئه لتحمي اطفالها
لتقييم من الثلوج والشتاء ستكون اصعب
المشكله ان التمويل المطلوب او الذي
المطلوب حتى نصل الى كل من يحتاج الى
المساعده غير موجود هناك تمويل ولكن ليس
كافن لان الاحتياجات تزداد يعني احتياجات
اللاجئين والنازحين مع كل عام تزداد وي
المطلوب اكبر ولكن في ذات الوقت هناك
ازمات كثيره في العالم
الدول التي عاده تتبرع لتمويل هذه
العمليات الانسانيه اصبحت توزع على ازمات
كبيره هناك ايضا بديش اقول نسيان ولكن
اصبح الوضع السوري يجب ان نبذل جهد اكبر
لتذكير العالم باحتياجات اللاجئين
والنازحين السوريين ولهذا شكرا للجزيره
التي تسلط الضوء على هذه المعانات يعني
بدي اعطيك مثلا كل عام المفوضيه لديها
برنامج مساعدات الشتويه هذا بالاضافه الى
المساعدات النقديه الاعتياديه على مدار
العام وكل عام تقريبا هذه هذا البرنامج
يمول بشكل كامل ولكن للاسف نحن اصبحنا
الان في شهر شباط ومع ذلك هذا البرنامج
ممول فقط حوالي 40% هذا يعني انه كان يجب
ان نصل الى حوالي
الملايين واربعه بالعشره مليون لاجئ ونازع
خلينا نتكلم بصراحه اذا امكن رولا لانه
كما قلت يعني كما قلت يعني هذا الامر
يتكرر كل سنه وبالتالي هل تقوم الجهات
المعنيه بمسؤولياتها بالفعل والازمه اكبر
مما يستطيعون التعامل معه ام هناك تقصير
وربما اذا انتهى هذا التقصير ستكون الامور
افضل
يعني التقصير هو بالدعم وهناك دعم مطلوب
للناشئ للناجحين واللاجئين وللدول التي
تستضيفهم لانني كما قلت الوضع يزداد سوء
الاحتياجات تتضخم نحن الان وصلنا
بالمساعدات الشوطيه فقط لواحد فاصله تسعه
بالعشره مليون بينما كان يجب ان نصل الى 3
مليون
هذا يعني نحن يعني للتوضيح ايضا المساعدات
تقدم لمن نقول انهم الاشد ضعفا وليس
للجميع رغم ان الجميع محتاج للمساعده
وللدعم
يجب ان يكون هناك التزام دوري والتزام
اقليمي ايضا ومن الدول المجاوره والقادره
لتامين ابسط الامور وابسط الدعم الى هؤلاء
في ظل هذا الوضع السيء كما اختصار هل يمكن
باختصار ان تقولي لنا يعني دور المفوضيه
في هذا الموضوع
طبعا المفوضيه كما قلت هناك مساعدات نقديه
على مدار العام هناك مساعدات شتويه داخل
سوريا هناك توزيع مواد
بطانيه
مراتب
وسائل تدفئه خارج سوريا في الاردن في
لبنان هناك مساعدات نقديه ولكن للاسف مثلا
في مصر لم يتمكن المكتب لدينا في مصر
لتقديم اي مساعده للاجئين السوريين في مصر
بسبب نقص التمويل وكما قلت على في كل هذه
الدول كان يجب ان نصل الى اكثر من 3.4
مليون وصلنا فقط الى واحد فاصله تسعه
مليون الان يجب ولكن هناك وقت يعني اذا
توفر التمويل دائما هذه المساعدات تمتد
ولكن يجب ان نكون ايضا
متواضعين في مدى ما يمكن ان تحله هذه
المساعدات تخفف ولكن للاسف الحل الجذري هو
ان تنتهي هذه الازمه نتمنى
الرحيل عن قيامهم والعوده الى بيوتهم وان
يكون لديهم حلول دائمه تمكنهم من اسرهم في
هذه الظروف نتمنى ذلك ونتمنى التوفيق لكل
من له دور في ذلك شكرا جزيلا لك من عمان
المتحدثه باسم المفوضيه الامم المتحده
لشؤون اللاجئين
[موسيقى]
اليوم العالمي للطفل اليوم العالمي
للعداله الاجتماعيه اليوم العالمي ليتامى
الحروب ويوم المراه الى العالم واليوم
الدولي للاخوه الانسانيه واللائحه تطول لا
يكاد يمر اسبوع دون ان تطرق الاذان حكايه
عن اليوم العالمي لشيء ما ماذا حققت هذه
الايام الطويله للبسطاء والفقراء ولياليها
المدلهمه في قصص الظلم والازدراء لضحايا
الاهمال والتشريد ماذا حققت الاطفال
والنساء وهم يموتون بردا وجوعا وعطشا
وحسره هناك مسؤوليات للمنظمات الدوليه
والجهات الرسميه لكن هل يعفي ذلك الافراد
والمنظمات الاهليه العبء ثقيل ثقيل بدليل
ان الفق مستمر ومعاناه الجياع والايتام
مستمره وربما تتفاقم ليله سعيده وخاليه من
الهموم نتمنى حالكم
[موسيقى]